heures m'écouter c'est extraordinaire la
façon dont vous raisonnez en ce moment
d'ailleurs moi je tiens je suis sûr que
que beaucoup de téléspectateurs 9 me
soutiendront je suis scandalisé par la
façon dont dont la télévision la radio
en général présente la situation
internationale
c'est à un cliquetis d'armes comme si
comme si comme soleil à des gens qui
meurent monsieur marché sait bien que
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il ya des
guerres locales
mais on présente les choses comme si
demain c'était la guerre mondiale d'une
nouvelle guerre mondiale comme si
c'était l'apocalypse mais enfin il faut
quand même être sérieux quelles sont les
forces qui se met en mouvement et qui
lutte en ce moment des forces guerrières
mais non parce qu'un histoire c'est pas
pacifiques mais c'est des forces
pacifique son temps mais comment les
faire comprendre ça monsieur marchand
les gens sont venus de milliers de
kilomètres mais bénéfique prenons les
différents mouvements mais c'est s
étaient des guerriers les hommes qui en
angola au mozambique enfin disons dans
toute l'afrique ont engagé la lutte pour
l'indépendance
pour en finir avec la faim de
sous-développement et l'analphabétisme
c'est des guerriers ces gens là n'ont
cédé hommes qui veulent vivre comme des
hommes et non comme des bêtes
ça c'est vrai mais les cubains sont
guéris milieu c'est des guerriers
l'église et le peuple iranien
je n'ai rien de commun avec l'ayatollah
khomeini c'est clair mais l'ayatollah
khomeini il a réussi cette
extraordinaire tour des forces de
mobiliser son peuple sur deux objectifs
premier objectif chasser le chat qui a
les mains couvertes de sang qui a
assassiné des centaines de milliers de
badauds de patriotes d'iraniens
d'iraniens le deuxième but et deuxième
objectif de redonner à son pays
son indépendance en finir avec la
domination de l'impérialisme américain
c'est une force de guerre ou une force
de paix le peuple iranien attend des
soirées regza sont l'iran monsieur
marché sur l'ironman au 90e rang une
norme à hanghzou chaléat jamais allé au
bout d'une démonstration
c'est sur votre exemple mais c'est au
nombre de questions monsieur marché
monsieur messer vous connaissez la
formule de l'émission soyez détendu mais
maintenant je n'accepte pas voulu
abandonner rang je veux répondre sur
l'iran tout à l'heure à brel à une
feuille de papier inscrivez votre resto
alors voilà on mettrait bien je veux
aller au bout de mon raisonnement
générant jeu